[Aplausos]
aguentaram
é um prazer estar aqui eu venho com 12 6
vezes a madeira não quer seguir quando
não convidaram para vir e não sabe bem o
que quer e nem sequer sabia o que era o
inter pode guardar não sou de outra
geração do outro em paz e à posição de
saber que o importante é contar uma boa
história e isso faz com que eu disse que
sim sem saber bem o que é
então eu pensei em a a não ser que eu
vou falar eu estou tentando falar com
esse cenário tem mas falar em 18 minutos
elas vão 30 segundos na tv para dizer
nada é tão a há uns que gosto muito e
vocês aqui toda a gente já ouviu dizer
que está em jogo então não está nos
açores ficam em são miguel está com
sotaque micaelense que não tem mais
relação com nada no português nada nada
nada é uma coisa um som tão fora do
normal em toda a minha vida ouvi isso
outra vez não em relação ao menos em
relação aos só na minha terra tem uma
coisa então se pode escrever sobre isso
e não pague mas ele não tem é só ter a
minha caranga era mais novo mas eu não
trago imagens povo falar soluções
só não se pode escrever sobre um dia fui
convidada por uma amiga minha que é
professora de literatura comparada na no
final da rua pra eu falar sobretudo
rural e eu ouvi falar sobre histórias
que só tem jeitos o valência gente mas
quanto rural mesmo terreno som das
pessoas de jett em duas horas e tal os
alunos a falar com alguém disse assim a
você via escrever isso ele não responde
porque eu fui pra que contar oralmente
histórias que não se podem não podem ser
escritas bom então essa questão dos
ataques aconteceu porque as pessoas têm
sempre a ideia de que a gente tá aqui o
destaque do utah que tem não tem aquela
magnífica história do dos tiros que diz
que um papa
tim cook vai na água o peixe pai vai com
pesquisa da língua e daí para cima na
direção contrária outros países e o pai
pergunta o peixe
outro espanhol assim ele diz que falta
água
assim o que é água
assim a gente nota que tem gente fala
normalmente a minha pátria é a língua
um indivíduo do dacar márcia fala sempre
foi assim solta pois quando vai ouvir os
outros
o normal é por exemplo as línguas o os
sons são assim a gente tem uma língua é
falada trabalho único grande pessoas e
se nós fizéssemos o registo no ano no
ecrã do computador os vários sons é que
em média os ou média o que a gente diz
que é o normal é o normal o que a gente
sabe tua e não só com o ouvido quando
alguém tem um só a seguinte para cima
muito problemática até então a que é
normal é que a norma que têm nenhuma
normalmente na hora do embarque deve
falar bem porque estava um som médio não
sinto à vontade nem ao desvio e ainda
por cima as suas expectativas clima não
vou dizer quem sabe falar é o algarve
onde a clinton pronto
saldanha é isso aí é o sotaque é o outro
estava com pressa e da época
assim toda a gente tem o sotaque - mundo
e hoje corrijo isso porque a 35 a 35
anos aconteceu uma história
eu dou obter 50 um livro chamado a opção
da portugalidade que tem para escrever
sobre a língua e tenta desfazer alguns
mitos que as pessoas têm sobre as
línguas acham que a língua é assim e
lingüiça de extorsão assim por causa da
língua o que eu procuro dizer que não é
assim não é língua é sim por causa
daquilo que nos solos e vou tentar
explicar isso
os poucos minutos um dia eu lesse uma
quebra no 11º com 25 anos e portanto uma
das coisas que acontecem depois tentar
explicar
quando os milhões de adultos e aprender
uma língua nova aprenderam consultar que
faz parte daquilo que eu quero explicar
aqui isso do sotaque como é que é
eu amo nessa aula é um valor que não têm
tempo a explicar como é que isso mas eu
costumava a onu vem ter comigo antes da
aula dos cursos começaram perfeitamente
normal um atleta e vem e começar a falar
com ele e vou imitar o lula não parece
fazer pouco deu mas para vocês verem
como é que ele falou comigo e eu disse
assim a equipe seguiu a tradição
preservando sem custo e continua a
explicar e eu disse que era surdo mudo
eu disse eu não sei depois de receber
mais tarde qual é a história da minha
mãe com portugal são um elemento do pai
e mãe postou uma transfusão de sangue
a transfusão de sangue hoje nos faz isso
naquela altura faça trânsito complicou
questão e eu te vi completamente perdeu
o feto os nervos e ele veio audição e
fala a mãe que deixou o mundo aprender a
linguagem gestual nunca quis que só quer
aprender seus lábios aprendeu nos lábios
e praticidade perfeitamente normal até
abrir a boca
então eu não ouvia nada eu tinha diz
campo forma tenham luz vermelha quando
ele viajou nem sabia que alguém queria
falar com ele então não tava mensagens
antes dos telemóveis
hoje seria muito diferente de hoje a
vida pra mt diferente por causa do
telemóvel ou então url to run a o é
preciso que o senhor dá autorização para
um ano um novo itaquiraí como para as
aulas para notas ea das coisas que eu
não percebo explicar é preciso que surja
dessa transição para eu vir mas também
mais
era bom que o senhor não usasse não
voltasse muita cara pro quadro porque
quando se vira a cara no quadro eu não
posso ouvir nada
olha o poder à vontade quanto virar a
cara por quadro eu vou tentar a gente
não é fácil p você perder a aula não tem
pra mim todas as vezes que for preciso
pois dá aula
encontramos e as dez minutos 15 minutos
espanhol para a aula primeira aula do
ano baseado não em inglês colin e venho
a cabo eo futebol eric isso é falso e eu
digo sim foi um título quase nenhum
chutes um pedido de bebê pois esse top a
pele
naquele momento eu já tinha me muito
sobre a língua e que tem aprendido muito
comigo pois que com imigração ovelhas
crianças paulo são nem os dois
seminários sobre mim está tudo seguindo
os movimentos dos lábios também a
maravilha
os ingleses dizem os que fazem o público
em geral a moeda com dados em arma
importante falar a ele como nosso carro
ligado que eu fiz até agora não foi
aquilo isso eu estava em casa mas o que
é amar assim em pretende bom eu quando
fala se em tudo cultural ea água
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é isso mesmo a questão é que não é só os
lábios sei cara toda e não é cara o
corpo todo quer dizer o mato e tudo em
inglês press tv dizer que a língua é
como a ponta do iceberg
um iceberg em um nono fora d'água o
resto está por baixo a cultura ea
cultura ea a23 cultura cultura das artes
das letras das idéias novas e cultura
conceito tradicional dos latinos a
cultura era tudo aquilo que resulta da
transformação sobre a natureza e
sobrevida feita com seres humanos
isso é cultura a apicultura cultura das
baías continuar no campo é transformar o
campo então os dados podia ser sociais
cultura é tudo isso então o modo como as
pessoas se relacionam com os outros uma
sua postura deles preto o mundo reflete
pessoal tudo seguinte portanto mesmo e
refletem sua impotência segundo quadro
para então em um só um saiu sim a urbs
tocar também trazem idéias sinto bem
sabem qual o diálogo mais mais cultura
da lusofonia do brasil eles falam então
tá
a banda afinal todos os cursos e agora
com a globalização gostamos muito
influenciados muitos outros totalizaram
cujo as viagens mas se alguém não sai da
sua terra quanto mais em ficar na sua
terra
mas os músicos que nós usamos são usados
da mesma maneira numa terra
diferentemente da outra terra ea gente
observa que não têm casa portuguesa que
ela eu tenham únicas como ela mesma
distância em outras foram hoje domingo
da fé pois as pessoas fazem muito tempo
fora porque o esgoto perguntar se
preocupar com isso tá bom mas então isso
é essa quando os italianos têm uma
língua que ele não os italianos porque
são assim cantando e criar uma língua
cheia de cair jogo alison 1
1 e língua que faz usam mais os alemães
criaram aquela língua com a língua deles
é assim que o inglês também ea e da otan
é idéia central do projeto é a um som os
sons vem daqui mas todo suporte apoia
isso portanto essa idéia agora o que
acontece com as crianças
eu já fui falando essas coisas nas aulas
de amigos é certa nunca escrevi sobre
isso também não fez nenhuma oferta nem
convidar um bom toque e não seremos os
benefícios cognitivos como é que
funciona há várias coisas que eu vou
fazer
antes disso o time paranaense quer nos
sabemos o cheiro menos 1 500 animais
uma girafa 11 junho em poucas horas e 45
minutos
uma girafa e em poucas horas
leva 25 anos é é bom porque um ser
humano e ambiente e uma grande interação
entre genética com é enfim esse a volta
desse diálogo foi a frança que maravilha
tão bom tão bonito ouvidas queriam
crescer
os quatro anos de gestão
os qualquer criança um chinês que nasceu
em nova york que neste momento bom venho
aqui e lá eu tenho luz é um dos 12
acusados são totalmente obrigando o modo
como falam porque eu já só vi as
crianças absorvem mas hoje eu posso
falar dos a vontade agora há estudos
eu também entrei em contato com
indivíduo com um médico publicou um
artigo bem e sabe se hoje que as
crianças lei lábios cinco meses
leone e mais se há pessoas que falam as
duas línguas diferentes as crianças
percebem as duas não são capazes de
falar eu podia falar sobre o assunto e
se na minha filha lynn 4 agora eu
ensinei a ea técnicas complicadas que os
autores têm um vídeo sobre isso mas que
vem confirmar essa criança percebe que
não sabe escolher uma criança ler lábios
e que as falhas que imitam essa em que
as crianças de qualquer sítio do mundo
falam imitando não é centrista que os
países nos pisos dos amigos das crianças
ninguém quer falar com os pais quer
falar com bom humor como começou então a
essa espécie de estudo do meio e uma
criança com a chance que eu estava
falando daquela maneira
portanto é assim que o sotaque vai ficar
ainda vai ser transmitido até não tem
muito mais tempo resolvendo alguns
exemplos como o rio tem aqui uma semana
entre eles 11 uma carga de histórias
culturas humanas baseadas na mão amiga
minha se não fossem os mesmos
organização da copa depois de anos são
miguel que faz tal é mesmo verdade fala
em galã fazendo bem falar com o sotaque
da sua terra então ela uma vez ela com
tecnologia no continente
na bahia mais um café e um balão em
patrulha e uma carcaça com que o edital
ea senhora lagarde assim mesmo que
citada a fonte
acredito
como a moça do maranhão das capelas
aquele tempo ouviam da promoção do ela a
irmã ea hospedeira nunca tinha ouvido
falar mal do gol e em queda mas nova
enquete do que fazer é a primeira
palavra e vai lá imagina carta enviada a
mensagem da irmã distraírem passado
explodia mil visitas e l nenê paulo para
mim mas aí e não há o brasileiro lê
hotel depois a mulher a mulher então
assina um ponto entrou e dá de cara com
maria kirilenko espera aí contrato foi
até que a morte os separe
[Aplausos]
usa isso essas marcas ele é real porque
isto é o brasileiro é o de passar
continuar porque fala conta muitas mas
já encontraram andré onde são miguel
quando se gosta muito isolada dos
funcionários são miguel não gosto nada
mas é um gesto de são miguel terceira e
está no palco que perguntar ao pessoal
docente do doutorado
gosto de imagem ele dirige eletr 28 de
dezembro em função da mesma opinião das
botas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
são jovens são jorge é um dia muito
calmo pois é a primeira vez que vai
ouvir o som já fazia jovem planejava
amanhã
ricky martin e vendedores ambulantes em
armar do sul jardim clube ganhar mais
uma semaninha olha ele aí impunes
absolva com essa por assinatura e acaba
já e e atua quase a chegar ao fim a
várias mas vou contar uma da minha terra
uma zona de sombra é um bom negócio só
uma idéia é montar estruturas versão
leão você não casa com a minha família
elas são duríssimos só tem um problema e
huck usou lino ea seguir o marido no neo
soul janelle gente pra ganhar o meu
projeto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
só ele teria que disputar o seguinte
você vai ouvir então por dois homens na
minha terra mundo num negócio ritmo
muito é a terra e os anos 60 autorizado
a vender dívida junto ao banco em que
ela estava triste por ela eu estava na
minha visão de negócio me passa por lá
veio e 6 é tg5 empreste ele semana
quando vim para aqui vão de 2015 um
contrato bom nem o banco vende empreste
dinheiro
bom mesmo é só pagar a conta que todas
as vezes que pollyanna diniz eram
semelhantes assim tem sotaque e você
acha que não tem o real
[Música]
[Aplausos]